mission is like he's your boss so your
boss can take your opinion into account
but at the end of the day he has the
final say and men don't they don't feel
like they're respected if you don't give
them the final say like they don't want
a woman that they have to argue with all
the time sex yeah but you don't have to
argue with a man to get your point
across if you're with a loving
respectful man who hears you and values
you he's always going to listen to you
he can he can hear you and listen to you
and still tell you no
if he tells me no
it depends like there's there's certain
things that yeah I might be like okay
cool I'll submit to you because I would
say I am definitely a traditional woman
and there are you a virgin
sorry I'm saying how are you a
traditional woman is a 22 year old
virgin